قلبي مركز الاعمال الذي فونسي باريس يستعد
اسامه الخليفي لبعث شركه المتخصصه في
التكنولوجيا
لا استطيع
منذ سنه ونصف كان نائبا في برلمان التونسي
الى حدود تعليق عمله من قبل الرئيس سعيد
وحله في وقت لاحقا
مواصلين النشاط السياسي واصلين دفاعا على
الشرعيه همم
الانتخابات
لقاعده
مظاهر الانتخابات
ال 17 من ديسمبر التصريح لوسائل الاعلام
الاجنبيه
اقعدوا ينتظر الشعب الداعمه لقيس سعيد
يؤكد وانا تصحيح المسار سيمر عبر البرلمان
الجديد
تجاذب سياسي لا علاقه له بمطالب الشعب
وبانتظاراته وقطع حقيقي مع المنظومه
السابقه المبنيه على التجاذب الحزبي الذي
تجاوز حده في تونس
بعد عشر سنوات كان نائبه عن التيار
الديمقراطي في مجلس النواب تعود سامي عبده
الجديد
تعتبر وسامي عبود هذا الاقتراع مهزلا
لكننا ستتابع ما يجري بكثير من الاهتمام
وفي انتظار من سينجح في دخول البرلمان ما
زالت الاسلاك الشركه جسيمه على احد ركائز
البناء الديمقراطيه للدوله